dad you said that when I turned 118 I  can go up to the world like every other  adult my kids to come and go from this  hotel but maybe wavy its that's a little  bit dad 30 years ago you promised I  remember we're both eating mice and you  specifically said that you gave me your  work good morning maybe wavy happy  birthday mer unit or MOOCs all talk  tuscan expo after eight hundred years  you've run out of time i'm already  you're rehearsing it on me you said you  were just thinking about i am just  thinking about it is very hard everyone  deserves a defense every person matters  Jim what do we deserve do you know how  people will look at us the family of a  man trying to free a traitor  that's for six people so for just me  that's gonna last 300 Sol's which I  figure I can stretch to 400 if I ration  so I got to figure out a way to grow  three years worth of food here on a  planet where nothing grows luckily I'm  the botanist